Things are looking really, really, really
bad for Rudy Giuliani to have Rudy Giuliani's
key employees have been arrested for their
work in connection to Donald Trump's Ukraine
scandal and Rudy Giuliani himself is now under
criminal investigation.
It was a big weekend, that's for sure.
Uh, the two guys we're talking about are Lev
Parness and Igor Fruman.
They are associates of Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy Giuliani is of course Trump's personal
lawyer or is he more on that a little bit
later and they were arrested just before leaving
the country on one way plane tickets.
Now, isn't that such an amateur mistake?
You don't buy a one way ticket.
If you're trying to flee from potential criminal
charges, you buy a round trip ticket, pretend
that you have every intention of coming back
to the United States and then just don't use
the return.
It's an incredibly amateur move that these
two guys did.
In any case, there are arrests or for a scheme
that violates campaign finance laws.
It relates to the pressuring of Ukraine to
investigate and smear Joe Biden as we've been
following for weeks.
Now the charges are for illegal campaign donations
and it is all very, very dirty.
So understand that the role of these two guys,
they're sort of the equivalent of Trump's
Watergate henchman.
They don't work for Trump.
They work for the guy that works for Trump.
In this case, Rudy Giuliani, and it's all
starting to look and sound and smell and feel
more and more like Watergate every day.
In many ways.
They were trying to leave the country and
were arrested.
Literal flight risks, trying to escape justice
for their potential crimes carried out in
service to their boss, Rudy Giuliani, who
is of course doing Donald Trump's dirty work,
and then as if that wasn't bad enough, that
gets us to Rudy Giuliani himself.
We learned that Rudy is under federal criminal
investigation for his Ukraine dealings.
New York federal prosecutors are now investigating
Rudy Giuliani criminally to see what lobbying
laws, if any, were broken.
Rudy Giuliani asked about it, of course, says,
Oh, nothing to see here.
It's all nonsense.
I'm doing everything fine.
It's all on the up and up and now we will
have to wait and see.
We'll Rudy Giuliani ended up charged, which
would be just delightful if indeed his actions
are worthy of criminal charges.
We don't really know that much as of right
now into a about this criminal probe into
Rudy Giuliani.
We don't know how advanced it is.
We don't know how long it's been going on.
We don't know whether Rudy Giuliani will end
up charged and in, so for what?
But what is happening right away, and this
was predictable.
I tweeted about this just a few days ago.
What is happening right now is that all of
a sudden Donald Trump is not sure anymore
whether Rudy Giuliani is still his lawyer.
It's kind of weird, right?
Sounds like a joke.
But I tweeted last week half-jokingly that
this was going to happen and it is.
And we're going to talk about that, uh, after
the break.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
D Pacman.
Follow the show on Twitter at David Pakman
show and make sure that you're following us
on Twitch because we will be live streaming
tonight,
presidential debate, a democratic primary
presidential debate at twitch.tv/david Pacman.
I hope to see you there.